first trip to America yes musky that
fixed anything edible in there um
I am XML from FX guide.com for wired and
welcome to our guide to you rump and
mating dancers yet the British Maji
zoologist arrives in New York after
being expelled from Hogwarts in JK
Rowling's new world a fantastic beasts
and where to find them
yes where is this man
[Music]
so you gotta go the case full of
monsters huh
he's travels fast
it's a look why would I have to wear
something loaded because your skull is
susceptible to breakage under immense
force one of the many creatures that you
must deal with us a kind of magical
Horning rhino beast on heat known as you
rump it
seen here in a shot that was actually
added quite late in production with our
heroes trying to capture the creature on
ice
one of the highlights of the films came
actually from just five words in JK's
original script which elegantly just
stated mute does a mating dance the path
from this to the screen involved
eighteen foot fiberglass puppets
choreographers animators and the lead
star Eddie Redmayne actually acting out
complex video selfies and then sending
them to director David Yates the actual
effects work fell to Tim Burke and
Christian mance and the team at frame
store now where many companies
contributed from MPC method Deena Katz
any site and others it was frame store
and the the Britta legacy from creating
Dobby in the original Harry Potter films
that led to this outstanding character
work in this particular film Eddie was
completely committed to working with the
character team as early as possible
actually filmed himself with some help
from his choreographer from the Danish
girl for his side of the mating ritual
and then sent that to director David
Yates the Ron Pizza animation approach
was actually typical of a different way
they worked with characters in this film
frame stars animation supervisor public
grillo was given quite a lot of time
before principal photography not just to
have the team look at designs but
actually animation studies of all the
creatures in the film problem the team
therefore managed to work out the urine
pants making ritual well before the
actual filming started this allowed the
team behind the warhorse stage
production puppet to build a 18 foot
high 20 foot long form a new rum pant
rig out of fiberglass and learn all the
Pablo's sexy moves Eddie would then
rehearse with this giant puppet and in
fact worked out with it on set
once the framing and timing was right
the team was then able to remove that
and of course film a clean plate was
just Eddie and then add in the character
in post-production with just this superb
interaction with Newt this approach of
using puppeteers was actually use on all
of the cast of creatures in the film
from the boat rouxelle to the young
Marmite now we often and I guess quite
rightly focus on the creative skills of
the animators but increasingly it's
these puppeteers on set led in this case
by Robin diver who are producing this
terrific interaction for the actors that
allow such believable performances to
captured nothing to worry about that is
a Mert that well don't forget subscribe
for more behind the scenes action
I'm Mike say more for wide was that
everything that came out of the case
time's running out let's just go